sad news related to Louis J Gomez and
the whole Legion of ganks Channel
deleted from YouTube today out of
nowhere I don't know if you've heard
about this yet but their whole channel
was removed earlier today have you heard
about this yet and what are people in
that Circle saying you know I just
launched my brand new show Tim butterly
show on YouTube and they uh gave me a
warning and took it down because we were
talking about a guy with a giant hog so
it's like they don't want you to say
anything these days dude like yeah
they're trying to censor me I just want
to talk about this dude's enormous
unit been about 2 months since
you've been legally adopted by Louis J
Gomez what's the worst part about being
his legal son so far it's actually it's
a Dream It's you know I was ready to
on this guy and say like he never
picks me up on time he's he's
inattentive he's it's all about his
girlfriend you know but I just he's the
most tender nurturing guy it's crazy and
I had to get punched in the face by him
to find that out yeah for sure